all right yesterday president Trump's
attorney wordy Giuliani told The
Associated Press the president will not
answer questions from robert muller
about obstruction of justice
the mayor is now with us the president's
attorney mr. mayor good to see you sir
how are you oh yeah
okay so obstruction is off the table
they're not even asking for it or no no
they're asking for it and and the only
way we would ever consider it is if we
got the questions on collusion first
which we've which were agreed to do
we'll review them is there fair is that
comprehensive if there's no holding back
of questions so they can ask questions
that are later round if it's if it's
done in good faith then when we finish
that will sit with them and talk about
any further questions whether it's all
mine any further questions on collusion
or obstruction problem with obstruction
is this it all takes place
post-presidency to agree to it would
really be to waive major presidential
privilege also it would involve very
very deep conversations that are very
much within the executive branch of
government and finally they don't need
it one of the things they would have to
show is they have particular eyes need
in otherwise they couldn't get it any
other way so far every question that we
think they're gonna ask they have the
answer to it and 1.4 million documents
got him again this surprised me to find
out Dom McGann the White House Counsel
gate 30 hours of testimony after 34 or
34 hours of testimony
you don't need anything up they have 1.5
million documents 32 witnesses
here's the big question on obstruction
why did you fire Comey well he doesn't
have to answer that it shouldn't have to
answer that he has the right to fire
article two plus they have the answer
take the less the whole tape play it
there's your answer now if you want them
under oath to repeat that you only want
them are those because you have some
nefarious purpose in your previous life
people kind of forget it's next week is
9/11 what 17 years later but in your
previous life before being the mayor of
New York you were a prosecutor so you
make this statement and I'll even say
maybe inarticulate but especially for
those outside
legal community in legal jargon what you
were saying and now inertia which
defended you strongly on this is that if
don McGann gives testimony you said
thirty four hours I thought it was
thirty and they interviewed the
president and he says one thing that
contradicts thought McGann they get to
decide who's telling the truth yeah I do
I want
do I want seventeen angry Democrats to
decide your Weissman and G near a no
give me a break I mean there that maybe
they've shown a little too much bias to
think that they would be objective and
fair and the reality is if it's a
one-on-one and he said she said that it
can be no determination of truth which
is why I said what I said I mean the
fact is even in a criminal trial you
don't prove truth you prove whether have
you proved guilt beyond a reasonable
doubt not all doubt reasonable yeah
reasonable doubt
so somebody innocent could be convicted
if it's beyond a reasonable doubt it's
not all that somebody that's guilty may
not be convicted because there isn't
proof beyond a reasonable doubt so you
got to be naive to think that it's a
search for pure objective truth what I
said was the only place you can find
truth is if you go to chuck Todd's a
little magic room and Meet the Press can
figure out the truth if he's doing
complaining about this no there's a
phrase in The Washington Post this week
talking about this anonymous the sleeper
cells have awakened in the United States
meaning the resistance within the
administration there's one line that
really caught my attention I was talking
about it earlier is that so we will do
what we can to steer the administration
in the right direction until one way or
another it's over why do I think that
should be a Secret Service investigation
and nobody seems to pick up on it this
is an unelected unaccountable anonymous
bureaucrat with top secret clearance oh
maybe here's the president talking about
war peace sources methods maybe he
decides that a very damaging piece of
information on national security should
be leaked because it would hurt Donald
Trump without regard to whether we hurt
the nation because whoever elected him
to be the repository of determining what
should be secret and what shouldn't be
secret this is a perfect perversion of
what it means to be in federal in
federal office
this man or woman what we think man
right unless he's lying about that too
right this man should quit and hold a
press conference that would be the
honorable thing to do
this is why I don't think it's any other
generals I don't think anybody ever went
to West Point
Pompeyo put it best Pompeo said I was
taught yeah if you disagree with the
boss you decide how important it is it's
not that important you stay if it's
conscience you leave and you stand up
like a hero this is no hero this is a
little slime de Ville it's also
dangerous dangerous succeeded me
dangerous because this man has decided
he's the repository trove of truth of
again what I'm telling you I mean all
these lawyers thinks they know truth
more than you know you know who knows
truth God well god knows truth we do the
best we can to struggle with it and
we'll hopefully we get close if the
president ran the president was elected
the president will be held accountable
the president the American people gave
him a seal of approval not this this
anonymous person all right it's very
good to see it now